twitch bands continue to make no goddamn
sense and to make things worse they even
seem to be helping certain creators
raise their profile
in some scenarios that it's little more
than a forced vacation that helps them
in the long run something has clearly
gone wrong so let's talk about it
[Music]
all right before we get into it I need
to remind you all that we have merch
it's beautiful stuff folks we got
crewnecks hoodies t-shirts and beautiful
colors all gaming Centric Esports lovely
stuff if you're interested head to
shop.thescore.com for more information
you can also click on the link in our
description and follow it to our site
alrighty so if you didn't know there's
been a bit of a streaming war going on
over the last two years but recently
it's hit entirely New Heights over the
last couple of years twitch saw a ton of
its big names experiment with streaming
on YouTube and in some cases flat out
jump ship team join me on YouTube gaming
time the future is now
even more recently things have been
Amplified tenfold with massive streamers
like Aiden Ross train wrecks and
potentially more leaving to stream on
the new dog in the fight kick but why
are so many people leaving
and why now well everyone has their own
reasons for leaving from twitch's brutal
Revenue splits to gambling to Andrew
Tate but one reason in particular has
long been at the root of this ongoing
issue twitch's TOS more specifically how
twitch's frivolous use of temporary and
permanent bands not only fail to better
the community but might actually help
certain streamers that receive them but
to understand how the hell this has all
gone wrong let's look at twitch's TOS
what is its actual purpose well at face
value it's a list of things that you
can't do on the site and although things
have been added over time twitch's to OS
is pretty standard for a social media
platform now nudity no racism no
terrorism no violating copyright laws
like that and although the idealist
would say that this exists to protect
the viewer Above All Else these rules
are in place to protect twitch from
getting sued or losing out on ad
potential basically they don't want to
hurt their pockets and this has been the
case since Amazon bought twitch back in
2014 but although their goal of having
an Advertiser friendly platform has
remained the same how they enforce it
has definitely changed right up to the
start of the pandemic getting suspended
was a big deal since it disrupted your
Revenue stream and in the ever evolving
scene that was twitch it could kill a
growing Creator on top of that twitch
was accused of having a bias when
handing out their bands making the
qualifications for getting one seem
arbitrary now although both these things
are still very much true at some point
things started to change and suspensions
became less feared by certain creators
one major instance we can point to is
the aftermath of xqc's famous twitch
Rivals band towards the end of 2020. too
many people here he's literally going
down wait dude okay it's a little bit
psychotic
foreign
[Music]
yes for those who have forgotten xqc was
banned for stream sniping during the
Jelly Bean game and at the time it
actually caused a fair bit of
controversy and for that lapse in
judgment X was slapped with a seven day
ban but it ended up not being that big
of a deal in the long run you see before
the ban xqc had been averaging about 40
to 60 000 viewers per stream but his
first stream back cracked 100K making it
his most successful stream in over six
months if this band was supposed to
deter xqc from breaking any more of
twitch's Rules by negatively affecting
his streams his return to the platform
suggests it failed to do that the same
thing happened to Aiden Ross after he
was banned for using a slurron stream
last April before that he was averaging
about 40 000 viewers per stream but once
again his first stream back hit over
100k viewers and it was his biggest
stream of the year at that time and
listen there are plenty of smaller
instances of streamers seemingly
benefiting from getting a suspension at
least from a metrics standpoint in this
current era of big streamers constantly
pushing the envelope it seems like
they're almost incentivized to increase
their notoriety even if it results in a
ban you can almost play it like a game
push the envelope come back bigger rinse
and repeat however things are obviously
much more complicated than that and a
ton of smaller streamers still suffer
from getting suspensions and there's one
big reason for why that is whether the
behavior is intentional or not creators
like xqc and Ross are able to get away
with these suspensions because they have
massive sponsorships and contracts
behind them for these creators the money
they make from subs and donations is
only a fraction of what they get paid so
the fact of the matter is they're
getting paid regardless this isn't the
case for streamers with little to no
sponsorships if they get suspended for a
week or a month that's no money coming
in which is devastating for obvious
reasons now the xqcs in Aiden Ross's of
the world are the exception and not the
rule but it doesn't make the pill any
easier to swallow and likely only Stokes
resentment smaller creators have towards
twitch and this is where we come back to
the root of the problem twitch's TOS is
just as confusing as it was three years
ago and this inconsistency isn't really
helping anyone as Hassan spoke after his
Infamous cracker gate incident although
there was a slight jump in his
viewership after the ban he'd be a lot
happier if twitch just took a hard
stance on what is and isn't allowed I
don't know what like twitch's goal is
it's the dumbest drama but it's
like take a stance dude because I know
this is a complex or complicated
situation a complicated issue but you
didn't have a problem eating
incel and Sim immediately when you came
out of the gate swinging and you were
like we're gonna make sure that people
can't be called incel or simp anymore
and it was like who are you protecting
in that situation that's so silly you're
being ridiculous and they stopped it and
they stopped they never banned anyone
for that and now it's like a similar
situation with crackers occurring and
they're like trying to figure this
out it's like I want to move on okay I
want to move on it's so stupid I don't
care it's just just make a decision and
this ultimately begs the question what
is twitch's goal here because having a
platform form with inconsistent bands or
some that even help certain creators is
clearly not fulfilling its purpose and
while this may have been something that
twitch could get away with in the past
when they were the only major player in
the scene there are plenty of other
competition that are ready to take the
throne now back when ice Poseidon got
banned for knowingly giving out
information that got a plane swatted he
was basically since there was nowhere
else for him to go and that's why he
begged for twitch to give him another
chance but twitch simply can't take
advantage of that anymore in the biggest
case we can look at is Doctor disrespect
back in June of 2020 doc was given his
infamously mysterious perma-ban but when
he finally came back his stream hit over
400 000 viewers larger than anything he
ever had on Twitch and according to
stream Hatchet that success continued
into 2022 and things are only getting
more complicated for twitch especially
with new streaming sites like kick and
Rumble coming into the mix sure Banning
Aiden Ross made a lot of sense the dude
was a TOS nightmare but the fact of the
matter is Ross is going to take his
audience wherever he goes and even if
kick and Rumble don't seed twitch losing
out on that viewership is only going to
help YouTube in the long run yes YouTube
does have similar problems to Twitch
where some creators think the
enforcement of their TOS is a little
arbitrary at times but what YouTube does
well is to strike the fear of God into
people with their three strike policy
you run the risk of having your entire
account banned regardless of who you are
now while I'm not saying that streamers
are intentionally getting suspended to
raise their notoriety getting banned is
simply not the end of the road anymore
and if Google suddenly decides to go
full hog into streaming and create a
revenue model that's actually attractive
to its creators twitch is going to have
an even bigger problem on their hands
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification Bell for Unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit us up on our Twitter
Instagram Facebook and tick tock